um no i i i think abortions are quote
unquote okay in
in in instances of grape and molestation
because if sex is non-conceptual sorry
if sex is con is consensual
and you had non-consensual sex and a
baby is a result of that
that actual act was non-consensual so i
get i understand why you'd want to get
rid of the child because the sex was
non-consensual so the child would be
non-consensual
if you have consensual sex
and the child is a result then you've
consented to having a child i'm just big
into like taking ownership like i just
feel like deal with the consequences
that you chose right like
like you you picked it and i said i'm a
pearl i made a um i done a live on
abortion right and i spoke about
specifically abortion within the black
community
sometimes black women bought their
babies three times higher than other
communities well isn't it but the reason
behind that is because planned
parenthood
more particularly was created for
it was a eugenics movement exactly yeah
it was like that's exactly it that's
like the main issue however that's
changed and more white women apparently
are getting abortions com okay you could
say no no because i've done the research
on it anyway i'm gonna go use the
restroom okay
wait wait what did you say
um
even even to this day um abortion
happens
per capita
more high within the black community
yeah right amongst and even though you
know even in america however many
percentage of uh however many percent of
america is actually white women
black women over-represent
abortion per capita
they over-represent it so it's like the
prison system in america black men are
over-represented in the prison system
even though the majority of people in
prison are white because america is a
predominantly white country but black
men are over represented given given the
percentage of black people within the
country so if you're only like 13
of black people in the country why do
you make up like 45
of the prison system does that make
sense so within when it comes to
abortion within the black community
black women um
uh
have
a certain higher percentage of abortions
per capita than other women and it's to
me like it's something that i feel quite
strongly about and you know it's
something that obviously women don't
want to really hear about do you know
what i mean because they get they accept
you but you know they they get in their
feelings about it but i'm just like well
why and
you can't my whole thing is you can't
scream quote unquote black lives matter
right if black lives don't matter before
they even get a chance to have a life in
the womb that's it um i've heard i'm not
i'm not positive this is correct but
i've heard the black population in the
us would be doubled today if it wasn't
for abortion probably yeah
since 1973 when abortion became um
became legal
in america
more black babies have been
more black babies have died um
cancer
more than cancer heart disease
violent crime hiv and aids combined wow
that's crazy combined
more people have died via abortion than
those combined since 1972. no i i just
can't get behind it because i have i
have that my brother
like um my my mom got pregnant when she
was 17. so she was like the she could
have aborted my brother right
um
and instead she decided to give him up
for adoption and he had a really good
life and
he is a sales software engineer he just
got married
um and she had every reason to get an
abortion if she wanted to she just met
my dad so i i just feel like my mom
understood she made that decision yeah
this is the consequence
everyone knew she was pregnant it was
really embarrassing she gave every no
one wanted her to give him up for
adoption everyone wanted her to keep her
she chose to give him up for adoption
right right and like she dealt with the
consequences and i just don't like i
just feel like women we lack
accountability for the consequences like
if you choose to be irresponsible
well i i i had i had a saying and i said
this on many podcasts
every woman is head of security for her
own vagina yeah you're a head of
security for your own vagina yeah so
whoever you let in
is up to you
and that's the same thing with girls
like
like for they'll complain about men or
trash men or trash like this this this
but you
you let them in yeah
yeah you let them in and it's like
that's why i don't really
i just grip between boys so i don't i
don't really stand with that kind of
[ __ ] right because i just that makes
sense because you probably
growing up when women grow up with guys
they they see two they see kind of both
sides to men they see like the really
dog
like really piece of [ __ ] men uh brother
is a hell i'm not right that's what i'm
saying so you see that and then you can
see these girls wild and they'll be
commenting on my tick tocks i'm like
what am i supposed to do right but then
you also see the good men you see that
yeah these guys are cool and you know
they're they're not so yeah i get it
when you go out with men you kind of see
both sides unfortunately the mena dog's
mantra has been the one that's been kind
of yeah thrown out yeah for the past
five decades
um did you find the study at all so what
i was gonna say um
i don't want to go with any of these
links that i have pulled up now just
because like because they show that
you're talking [ __ ] is that what it is
because they're mostly dot-coms like i i
want to go with like actual yeah
what do you call it like like actual
peer-reviewed articles and stuff like
that i managed to just find one so far
okay but i would have to actually read
this in detail it's 46 pages long okay i
don't want to have to go through that
but if you yeah
so it's like
a national study of
police sexual misc oh god this is very
long it is
and i couldn't even find anything that
blatantly sticked out
but just stuck out sorry i found when
people like say stats like that and i'm
sure you heard it somewhere like you
thought it would maybe was true um what
i know of it is not that um it's like
legal all over the u.s what it is is
that it's not illegal
in a certain amount of states i just so
what i'm sorry i'm sorry i don't know
you're good what i know of it as is that
it's like 34 or 35 states that don't
necessarily have a law against it
and there have been cases where
detainees have been assaulted meanwhile
in the rest of the states that do have
laws against it like you know that that
protects the detainee at least
so that just shows you that there's a
problem at all with it well i just
thought that prisoners can't legally
consent to sex
did you guys not hear about the two
prisoners
in the female prison oh no that were
impregnated by the trans person that was
in prison
two prisoners got impregnated by a woman
in prison because the trans person was
in prison
and did not hear about this yeah it was
crazy it happened in i think it was new
jersey as a matter it was it might have
been new jersey or baltimore or
something yeah but it was probably
baltimore yeah i don't know
we're not we're not going to rip that
into you
crazy it was crazy yeah
well it just like
yeah and then oh my gosh and then you
what if it was just a duties like i want
to get laid
i have a female
if it's consensual
i can't get mad at the end of the day if
the detainee and the officer really
wanted to go at it
by all means i don't think that's nice
but you know but the [ __ ] just
arrested you 15 minutes ago i don't know
why you would do that but
by all means do what you want but when
it's full-blown assault yeah
that's not good okay actually i have a
question for you so um it's going back
to we're talking about earlier with the
trans people and you're saying like you
empathize more with a lot with them
because of their like
feeling